I think I was very lucky this time
around in this course to have students
from so diverse backgrounds but also
students who I think most of them were
first-generation Americans and with
ancestry with their parents or
grandparents from quite diverse opposed
of the world from Mauritius from India
from Latin America and also in terms of
ethnicity and religion it was also
called a diverse set there were students
whose parents were Jewish there was a
family and students there were some from
India and they were basically struggling
with these notions of who they are in
terms of the identity and can you be
more recent but yet not speak the
worrisome creole language can you be
Indian and not speak both puri can you
be Latino that might be fluent in in
Spanish can you be a fan American but
yet not be fully fluent in so called
black English so those were questions
that they themselves brought in that I
think enrich the course because it
became very personal in many ways and
and I feel that through the semester did
themselves matured in in the kinds of
answers they were bring to these
questions which were deeply personal and
in fact once I discovered that they had
such diverse background so that the
questions were so personal in terms of
who they were as as individuals in terms
of identity language religion ethnicity
then what I asked them to do as the very
first exercise was to write what I call
the linguistic biography and actually
and I'm grateful that I get this hand
from a dear friend and colleague
professor and Chelsea Hadley who teaches
at UC Santa Barbara and I'm charity
actually shared with me her own link
biography and when I read that I realize
how powerful it was to read about her
own growing up in terms of language
ethnicity race so I thought that I would
ask students or something similar and
that helped me through the semester to
frame a kinds of questions we would
answer throughout the course which were
very connected
to the essence of the issue of language
and identity